bald will hört wie gesagt sie fühlt sich
so fett kommen zu einem neuen video und
leute ich glaube wir wissen alle worum
es heute geht okay wir müssen sich
vormachen es geht natürlich um gewesen
wäre es heute rausgekommen und wenn ich
sagen würde dass ich nicht auf twitter
zuges brent wurde mit aufforderung auf
den zu reagieren dann würde ich lügen
deswegen heute selbstverständlich opfer
ich mich auch für die gemeinschaft
verfehlt ja gar nicht bereit bist ja
leute in jeder community muss ein geben
der sich für andere aufopfert der für
andere da ist für andere ein steht und
der für andere leid auf sich nimmt damit
diese anderen das live plötzlich
ertragen müssen und der bin ich heute
ich werde heute ist video anschauen
gestern hat bibi den fremd geht es
gebracht okay wir haben alle das video
reingezogen es war geil auf jeden fall
wer von uns würde eher fremd gehen aber
das hat mich nicht so interessiert okay
relativ gesehen hat das nicht
interessiert dann kam heute die bombe
dort ist wo ab official video von bbh
ist draußen leute heute mit genau einer
stunde hatte die video gerade aufnehmen
der erste eindruck fällt genauso aus wie
man es erwartet hat community hat sich
auf dieses video gefreut und hat es mit
der sehr positiven reaktion aufgenommen
das sieht man auch an den like home
display schauen hier auf 96.000 likes
[Musik]
96.000 dominatoren und dem gegenüber
stehen nur 310.000 ist der like it's
like verhältnis von eins zu drei dass er
es eigentlich gut oder zum thema es gibt
geld für die klicks ok da fehlt uns
schon wieder was auf und zwar muss man
medienschau dort geben okay was muss
kurz mal klatschen denn dieses video
geht nicht über zehn minuten
ich weiß das klingt verwirrend leute
aber dieses video geht nicht über zehn
minuten sondern nur drei minuten 7.30
und das heißt keine sechs mit rotlicht
über heutzutage noch überleben aber
genug gelagert heute sagte allgemeine
rektoren funktionen deswegen film ab
gut als hintergrundmusik verwenden das
ist so copyright freie ukulele musik las
man leichter wenn ich das in meinem
nächsten video nicht im hintergrund
verwenden sollten ist das erlaubt das
sieht aus als wäre sie nackt davon darf
man daraus machen hat das ist ja fast so
eine kritische meinung aber wenn wir das
kann kann ich auch weiter aus wenn du
sowas nicht sehen wollt aber es wird
jetzt ob es das jahr 2017 leute videos
werden heute so gemacht wie ich gesagt
wie fühlt sich so fetzt warum das sind
vorschlägen leute erinnert euch noch
einmal letztes video da die wii so
gemeint sind die wachleute hatte eine
richtige messe ist es einfach eine
message macht man das messe ist die
erste die welt lange rutsche die haus
tag meine mutter die welt und die
botschaft ist ich fühle mich verriet was
weißt du die botschaft in dem video die
die positive botschaft
[Musik]
wieder gab es schon mal angeschaut und
mir ist aufgefallen dass 90 einfach nur
daraus bestehen das baby einfach in die
kamera grinst wie geht ein haus hat paul
klee outfit an und kämpfen die kamera
die videos die über bühne mache da geht
eigentlich nur darum dass ich gerne sein
möchte wie sie deswegen leute versucht
mein bestes verkehrt wir machen jetzt
zehn sekunden musikvideo mit mir los
geht's
[Musik]
so lief mit russland von dem husten
presse englisches hat auch nicht sogar
leute also wenn man so bis hinweise man
englische wort eigentlich ausspricht
finden gleich hätte lieber auf deutsch
singen sollen aber auf deutsch wäre
natürlich aufgefallen dass der text
kennt die kamera grinst ich kann nicht
mit herrlich brauche ich muss mein zweck
in krisen leute ich glaube ich habe das
richtige fashion store gefunden
justin hat mir das empfohlen danke
justin ist aus dem jüngsten ihre
kollektion warte ich habe drei t-shirts
und wie ist ihr welche art mit einem
gestellt hat ich war dumm für das album
kommt total bei mir an ok ich muss kurz
das hätte ich das album kommt die tage
an leute wenn immer mehr ankommt wenn
man damit andere was schönes machen
[Musik]
im buch alles klar baby werten
orientierte genug für die musikvideos
werden sie erst mal das video
anzuschauen
das wolle man nicht machen was ist der
ist der eindruck leute die kraftvolle
message okay die nachricht die
rausgetragen werden sollte zu
hunderttausenden von jungen mädel von
jungen männern freund sonst die menschen
die halt die videos vom bügel zuschauer
die messe transport und diese messages
ich fast einfach mal für euch zusammen
okay die kernbotschaft des videos ist
einfach falsch verstanden ab webb war
der biber butt butt butt barbie
barbapapas ich so von dem song mitnehmen
weiß es so abwärts weiter biberbach weil
normalerweise würde man ja eigentlich
denken hat bob bei der be bop so dass
wenn man eigentlich denken oder so also
normalerweise mitgenommen aber doch ganz
ist es eigentlich krassen jeder kann was
anderes mit dem von dem ist oder einfach
auf jeden fall also mein leben ist nicht
besser geworden ich habe nachgeschaut ob
ein konto habe einmal die doppelte menge
geld kratzer halt - die fünf euro die
ich für einen song geteilt habe
deutliches zwischenmeldung okay ich
möchte einfach dass wir als community
zusammen kommen und einfach miteinander
teilen was wir aus dem fang mitgenommen
haben also andrea hat was mitgenommen
noch mal vorab barbara die wada war
andré ich habe mir ehrlich gedacht so
bald wie die die dob und wenn ihr
irgendwas anders mitgenommen hat könnte
es erst mal die kommentare schreiben
jeder sieht es auch anders wie das
anders von dem song mit leute sonst
passiert in dem video einen finger so
wirklich fast deswegen werfen jetzt noch
kunden sneak peak in die lyrics okay
wenn ihr eine komplette analyse der lgs
haben wollt dann checke anderes kanal ab
okay andré macht wird auch ein video
dazu die leute schauen wir noch kurzen
die erste strophe rein es ist später die
nachricht gehe ins bett doch erhole mich
kein bisschen mein freund machte schluss
ich bin fast tot was ich werde mein
bestes tun müssen dass die motivation
wieder raus spricht krasse
stimmungsschwankungen für mich fest
ich habe keinen antrieb mehr darf nicht
mal die katze behalten aber so ist es
nunmal das war vor dem ersten einblick
in dieses video leute meine erste
reaktion darauf ich hoffe es hat euch
bisschen unterhalten so weit wenn babys
album bei mir ankommt wird auch noch was
lustiges mit dem album passieren okay
was ich will ich wieder was denkst du
schon zwar leicht sei und bis zum
nächsten mal